. OK.
We have an example today.
This is not me patting myself on the back,
but we have an example today of exactly what
I warned you about a couple months ago when
I did a story about populism versus social
democracy.
I did a story called Social Democracy is being
Destroyed by Populism.
This was a little while ago.
And I warned you about how the rhetoric of
populism can sound very good.
It can even sound like it's uniting left and
right in favor of the middle class or whatever,
but that the language can so easily be used
to bamboozle and trick people.
Trump used populist rhetoric in 2016.
Trump tricked many on the right and some on
the left with his populist rhetoric in 2016.
And we are now seeing the repercussions of
that in the current administration.
So I have an example for you today from Tucker
Carlson, which is exactly what I was warning
about.
There is more and more left wingers that are
sort of sympathetic to Tucker Carlson, who's
a Fox News propagandist, because Tucker has
been increasingly using the language of populism,
which sometimes sounds reasonable to hide
his horrible policy ideas.
Sometimes, Tucker, you turn it on.
It sounds like a white nationalist show, and
then sometimes you turn it on like last night
or the night before.
And you hear Tucker using pretty uncontroversial
populist language which could be implemented
with right wing policy or it could be implemented
with left wing policy.
And he did it again this week.
And there are people on people on the right,
of course, but there's even leftists just
gushing about.
Look at the common sense that we're hearing
here from Tucker Carlson.
And it's painful to see people fall for it.
I warned you about this in my segment recently.
Let's take a look at the clip.
Forget that in the end, the Republican Party
exists to serve the interests of normal people.
Ordinary people, middle class families are
the core of this country.
They are hope for the future.
Our only hope.
And yet both parties have shamelessly abandoned
them.
Families have no national spokesman.
They have no lobby in Washington.
Republicans pretend to be their champion,
you know, by now that they are not.
Instead of improving the lives of their voters,
the party feeds them a steady diet of mindless,
symbolic victories, partizan junk food designed
to make them feel full even as they waste
away.
Who cares how many Benghazi hearings we have?
We're supposed to care.
Why should we?
How did Peter destructs?
Text messages become more important than saving
American jobs from foreign nationals who are
taking them?
It is lunacy.
We fall for it every time and to an extent,
this show has participated in it.
We apologize with deepest sincerity.
So this is classic populist rhetoric that
is very similar on the left and right.
Federico Finkelstein from the New School is
very, very good.
He he's one of the foremost experts on left
versus right wing populism.
And we have looked at so many examples of
rhetoric that is populist rhetoric, which
sounds like it could be coming from a leftist
or from a lunatic right winger.
The party, you know, here, Tucker, is saying
the Republican Party should be serving the
middle class.
You hear Democrats sometimes use similar rhetoric.
We should be primarily serving the middle
class.
The middle class is the core of the country.
Politicians should focus on improving the
lives of voters.
He even mentions.
Tucker, does the silliness of Benghazi hearing
after Benghazi hearing and Peter struck texts.
And it's true.
That was nonsense.
Jobs matter more like he's saying things that
are true, but he can't even suppress the right
wing xenophobia.
He can't hold it back because he says, hey,
we we need the Republican Party to protect
us from foreign nationals who have taken our
jobs.
And that's the bubbling up of that virulent
anti-immigrant Tucker Carlson that we know
who has said immigrants make our country dirtier
and poorer.
And this is why the rise of populism on the
left at the exclusion of just a solid socially
democratic set of ideas is so dangerous.
As I've said before, social democracy is less
about rhetoric and it's more about a clear
set of policy ideas, including how do we get
health care for everybody?
Finance, education.
How do we tax people well.
How do we do policing?
There's so much policy and social democracy
when instead you start seeing populist rhetoric.
It can come from the left than right and it
can sound pretty damn good with no regard
to the policies that are actually being proposed.
So to be clear, you can have populist rhetoric
and socially Democratic policy.
OK.
Well, I mean, that that would be fine.
But people like Tucker Carlson and Steve Bannon,
to some degree and others, they're great at
using just the rhetoric to pull people in
to what in the end, at the other side of it,
you know, at the end of the rainbow, so to
speak, is a terrible set of policy ideas.
And Tucker couldn't even hide his dog whistle.
It's 95 percent reasonable populist sounding
rhetoric with foreign nationals, which basically
means, hey, we've got to keep those Mexicans
out.
Right.
That that's what's the policy prescription.
At the end of this.
So you have to listen much more carefully
because it sounds good.
We also shouldn't underestimate the effect
that Tucker's advertisers abandoning him might
be having on his rhetoric.
I don't know.
That's another story which we've covered,
Tucker.
Tucker's having major problems with advertisers
because of some of the white nationalist type
sounding rants.
Maybe this is posturing for those purposes.
I don't know.
But the point the idea here is listen to all
my populist sounding rhetoric, but my solutions
are xenophobia to support the middle class.
Stop immigrants from coming in.
So on and so forth.
As someone said to me on Twitter, this is
a shadow tactic.
It sounds reasonable.
You pull them in with the rhetoric, then you
drop the seed of populism when you think no
one is looking.
And then it's, hey, you know what, you'd better
vote for Republicans or Black Lives Matter
is going to come and take your house.
Right.
That's the that's the bamboozle.
That's the bait and switch that happens in
the end.
This is a polished way to tell us Mexicans
are stealing our jobs.
Black Lives Matter is going to take your house.
And we need to stop everybody.
So don't fall for this stuff.
Review that clip that I did about populism
and social democracy because this was exotic.
There's no better example of this type of
ruse that I warned you about six weeks ago
or whenever I did that story.
Then in this Tucker Carlson segment, let me
know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that you can get the entire show
in our audio podcast form every single day.
You can get it on whatever your favorite podcasting
app is, whether it's I, iTunes or podcast.
Sure.
Or whatever else, Spotify, etc., get that
daily audio podcast.
Let me know what you think about this populism,
social democracy.
Roo's on Twitter where you can find me
at CPAC.